hey guys Justin hey Walt here from
gamespot.com
were hanging out at San Diego comic-con
2014 and right now I'm in the wet
abouthe talking with Luke Walker who is
the mold room team leader for what uh
what is it that you do exactly for
wedding here well I'm in charge of
making sure that the products we make
and the props were making for films I
get reproduced in the right way so
whether it be for you know for a
computer game sort of publicity or for
an actual movie I make sure that what we
make and all the art that goes into it
gets to be the final product and they
made it in a way that's appropriate and
gets to be smashed around as much as it
can be so movies and video games you
literally bring the stuff to life and
one of the reasons that we're here is
because nothing stands out here at
comic-con more than this a massive smile
with dragon and I was told that you had
a direct hand making this this huge
creation yes well I'm the team back in
New Zealand they they made the model of
the dragon and then it was milled out
and a group of sculptors you know made
it look as good as it did and then it
was my job to get that sculpture and
reproduce it in a product called
fiberglass which was gonna be able to be
put up at their booth so I had to break
it into a whole bunch of pieces but huge
split lines in it and made sure it could
go up and only weigh about 1,200 pounds
yeah what is it that goes behind putting
together something that this is big and
lights up and it has moving eye parts
and it's a lot of scratching your head
and trying to figure out which ways you
can break things and break molds and
make sure that it does what you need to
do but it's a lot of reverse engineering
and then forward thinking and a lot of
experience comes into it and you also
have some more stuff on display here at
the booth I mean there's a lot of really
awesome weapons and neat things here you
had a direct hand in putting this book
together over here yes this this book is
a 20th anniversary of weather because
wet has been around now for 20 years the
company and Richard asked me if being
with the company for 14 years if I would
write the history of weather which there
was a very daunting task and I said I
would and yeah I decided to do the team
the best I could and give everyone an
insight into how the company but also
what is
we're doing there's quite a bit of
technical stuff in there which has been
a bit silly because I'm a bit of a silly
person but Italy it's a good read and
people can learn about how we make the
things we do and I think the Lord of the
Rings and The Hobbit have really
elevated what people know about and what
they think about whether but you also do
a lot of really cool stuff with
videogames and and I think you were
saying that you've done some work with
Tara
yes Tara approached us to do some
promotional items for their for their
game and so we've made some high-end
representations of their props which we
do as if it was like a any other feature
film and we've taken their models and
turn them into a physical thing and age
them and then then reproduce them as any
any movie prop so yeah that was quite a
cool project actually to to get such
very quite large fantasy designs and in
order to make them work physically it
was very very very hard but rewarding is
that something that the team uses for
reference or is that something that
they're gonna be selling what do they
use those life-size props for dip for
promotional things and also sometimes
just to giveaways and things like that
- I think Blizzard use us quite a lot -
for their staff to have presents and
things and it's just kind of fun
in order to see something that's a
digital thing and see how it would
actually be in physical what's cool it's
quite cool and Tara's not the only give
you've worked on there's some other
projects you've been doing as well yes
grey goo where did a whole bunch of
design our design team work working all
different fields and they did some
design work for grey goo and we just
come off a really really big franchise
that I can't really talk about but that
was a really awesome project like that
that really pushed us and we're all
really got behind it and it very happy
and hope the fans are happy once it
comes out that that we did the the game
justice well I know a lot of people will
be really excited to find out what that
is and you know everything that what it
does is is literally real looking like
it's something you can reach out and
touch thanks so much for talking with me
Luke you're welcome thanks thanks for
coming along and for even more San Diego
comic-con news stay tuned at Gamescom